Saudi Arabia's King Abdullah Saudi
Arabia one of our biggest allies in the
Gulf which doesn't let women vote or
drive but that's a different topic
altogether has introduced a series of
new laws which defines atheists as
terrorists and this is according to a
report from the Human Rights Watch and
this the laws basically have come into
play because of the growing number of
Saudis that are travelling to into Syria
to fight in the civil war there and then
they're returning to Syria with newfound
thoughts on freedom and they now have
all these new military skills and the
monarchy is basically afraid that all of
these new ideas is going to cause what's
happening in Syria to happen in Saudi
Arabia let's look at royal decree 44 it
criminalizes participating in
hostilities outside the kingdom with
prison sentences of between 3 and 20
years article 1 of the new provisions
defined terrorism as calling for atheist
thought in any form or calling into
question the fundamentals of the Islamic
religion on which this country is based
I thought as a Star Wars guy I thought
it was funny they're calling royal
decree 44 which sounds so much like
order 66 which is where they killed all
the Jedi but I don't have to tell you do
that ok we've got to to atheists here
right I mean I know you well enough and
I know your work well I don't believe
that there's somebody up there judging
me but I believe in a force basically
but I don't think I believe that they
something huh
I believe there's something happening
here that I can't really explain but I
believe in God I don't think God cares
how much I jerk off I think God whatever
you want to call God probably created
this little universe and now is creating
some others not watching even that's a
deist I think you'd be like in trouble
with right Saudis oh I'm sure would not
be thrilled but I think they'll make it
okay so all right so as a theist is
there is this the most bonkers thing
you've ever loved that I can be a
terrorist without doing anything
is less than Christian like it it's
doing less than being religious it is a
lack of belief so literally without
doing anything making any decisions
having any belief system or insights
into anything we're terrorists but can
you understand why a monarchy that has
so much control of their people and as I
said doesn't let women vote or drive yet
can you understand why that in a weird
way is more of a threat I can sort of
see why they'd see that concept as more
of a threat than actually terrorism this
is a problem with living under a
theocracy is that you're going to have
legislation in place that's morally
directed that's fundamentally based on
your specific religious values and it's
going to by its very nature target
individuals that don't fit into that box
and you know look at what's happening
right now in Brunei where the Sultan of
Brunei is passed Sharia law in this
country I mean it's [ __ ] insane like
I'd much rather go chop up someone's
hand now for all feelings if I go to
Brunei like I will be put to death in
five minutes like I will figure out how
to break some sort of law that will you
know they'd kill you they'd execute
exactly and so I'd rather go to Saudi
Arabia but these are shades of [ __ ] is
what we're talking about right now and
yeah the way that are you boycotting the
Beverly Hotel because Beverly Hills
hotel because that's owned by the Sultan
of Brunei I generally spend a lot of
money it's a Beverly easy boycott for me
but yeah I mean I think these are all
shades of the same thing you know if we
talk about oppression of women and we
talk about oppression of atheistic
values what we're really talking about
is a theocracy trying to maintain its
religious values which are patriarchy
and kind of core you know power in the
hands of the rich in the hands of the
people who who can use these kind of
religious codes to control the decisions
that the lesser lands in the I mean it's
a [ __ ] age-old story it's depressing
a [ __ ] that we're living in 2014 and
we're seeing this but it this doesn't
surprise me that Saudi Arabia makes
these decisions what pisses me off is
that there are
strong ally of America same as Brunei by
the way we're an ally of a country with
Sharia law and that's all because they
have oil so that's that's the next thing
I wanted to bring up and without getting
into major geopolitical discussion do we
have to reevaluate some of our alliances
on some of these places that have such
horrific human rights where they're
literally stoning gay people to death
and for the third time now women can't
vote and drive I mean it's such
fundamental basic simple human rights do
we have to reevaluate who were friends
with even though yeah they've got a lot
of oil and apparently we like yeah I was
actually just gonna pose that question
to you guys because it's like a really
touchy subject but I find it hard to
imagine that I'm in a country that's
supporting that type of environment for
people I feel so bad I get messages from
people all the time from the Middle East
and they're scared to even write me the
message because if somebody were to see
it they could be executed yeah so for
people that have to live in that or
people who are being killed because
they're gay like I just I just don't
understand why we would you know use
money as enough of an incentive to
support that type of environment and
that's the problem we're so entrenched
in this kind of American exceptionalism
and this political like whatever my
country thinks I think too that we
actually use phrases like why don't we
support I'm [ __ ] support but my
government does and that's unfortunate
for a lot of people because it makes us
look on the world stage like we are
willing to turn the other way we're
willing to turn the turn the other way
about these humans rights violations
which we are which we exactly and that's
the real problem I'm not right but as a
nation we are and that's basically
because of what you said it's that
dependence on oil and I think that if we
got to a place where we were less
dependent on fossil fuels and I'm not
even about foreign fossil fuels but
fossil fuels in general and we really
embraced a more green movement which is
helpful for a million reasons it's
helpful to the economy it's helpful to
the environment I mean there's only
positive side effects of making these
decisions we this won't even this
wouldn't be a conversation
Obama would immediately be like [ __ ] you
guys we're not going to give you aid
anymore not until you you know lift this
ban or not until you stop you know
killing people for their beliefs
Wow so even Obama's not above
ethics I can't believe all right final
thought is because we're talking about
atheism what what do you guys personally
say to the people that say there are no
atheists in foxholes so the people that
say on your deathbed you are gonna
retract everything you believe in [ __ ]
take it off horrible that's horrible I
know that Christopher Hitchens spoke a
lot about this whenever he was dying
yeah he definitely didn't take back
anything that he said and I think that
that's really an insult to your
intelligence saying you obviously can't
hold your beliefs true because if you
were in the situation you throw it all
away so you're almost in a phase until
you need God or religion or something
and that's just insulting to your
character and your intelligence yeah
it's also putting such a strange onus on
the Atheist I always think like their
can believe everything they believe in
for their entire it's just one more way
for them to say we're right and you're
wrong because one day you're gonna agree
with me and the truth is if we were
raised in a nation where religion was
never taught where there was no cultural
bias toward religion and then we went to
war for our country and then we found
ourselves in a foxhole we wouldn't make
up the concept of God like we're a
theist by default
religion is indoctrinated into us so of
course some people go back to their
earlier mentalities because they were
raised that way but I don't know any
atheist who in the late stages of life
who were never exposed to religion who
are all of a sudden like I'm going to
invent some sort of religion as a as a
means of feeling safe and comfortable
she's gonna bring that up I've met a lot
of people who are raising their kids
without religion and I've had a
conversation with a kid they're like I
just don't understand how people think
these crazy things you know I don't
believe in Santa Claus anymore
and I just think it's really important
that people could just step back and
imagine that they never had that a
doctor nation imagined that they never
were brought up with religion and then
tell yourself the religion story again
whether you're Muslim or Christian or
whatever you are it would sound
ridiculous so I want to ask those people
who ask me what I would do on my
deathbed well why on your deathbed
aren't you going to start praying to
Allah you know it could be wrong might
as well cover all the bases yeah and
that's that's you know a common thing
that they that they say kind of an
atheist circles which is that we're all
a theist I'd
go one god deeper